at the beginning of world Pride Month
and I want nothing to detract from the
inspiring this inspiring celebration and
both my personal and professional life I
do my best to act responsibly fairly and
respectfully over the past number of
years the NYPD has been forging new
relationships and repairing existing
relationships at times there are
obstacles that get in the way sometimes
those obstacles are easy to overcome and
sometimes they're not I think would be
irresponsible of me as we go through
world Pride Month not to speak of the
events at the Stonewall Inn in June of
1969 well I'm certainly not going to
stand up here and pretend to be an
expert on what happened at Stonewall I
dunno what happened should not have
happened the actions taken by the NYPD
were wrong plain and simple the actions
and the laws with the discriminatory and
oppressive and for that I apologize
I vowed to the LGBTQ community that this
would never happened in NYPD 2019 we
have and we do embrace all New Yorkers
and we are a department that is
inclusive we understand to move forward
and to keep our great city safe every
culture and every community must be
treated as equals and with respect we
are not perfect
but from what I see and what I know the
NYPD is made up of human beings that
want nothing more to fight crime and to
keep everyone safe
we at the NYPD are here to celebrate
we're all pride with you and most
importantly keep everybody safe during
this month-long celebration and as
everyone knows talk is cheap judges by
our actions today's gathering is a great
example of how these relationships can
grow to benefit our city and I'm proud
to welcome you here as we prepare for
another safe and successful Pride Month
and we know that living in a free and
safe community requires a daily
commitment by both the police and people
we serve it's our job to protect you and
we can best achieve that when we work
together those of you here already
understand that but it's clear that we
have much more work to do hate crime
stats for the first mine's five months
of 2019 or troubling we've seen spikes
in hate crimes overall which also
include a slight increase in crimes
motivated by sexual orientation in just
a few minutes Deputy Inspector mark
Mullen re the commanding officer the
NYPD's crime crime Task Force get into
some more details
the NYPD takes all reported incidents of
bias extremely seriously because we will
never tolerate hate in our city in any
form that's why a hate crime
investigators work 24 hours a day with
our precinct cops our detective squads
our local businesses and communities we
also have a dedicated liaison unit my
office and detective Carlock
specifically as our LGBTQ liaison
Carling want to stand up and wave I
think everybody knows you
should recognize that you were standing
up already sorry about that
detective Locke serves that serves as a
direct connection between NYPD and the
LGBTQ community he's available to answer
your questions and address any of your
concerns and encourage you to reach out
and get to know him he's a great
resource as well as our community
affairs officers and our neighborhood
coordination officers and in fact in a
moment our chief of counterterrorism is
going to give you some details about a
brand new initiative we're launching
called the lavender alliance it's an
enhancement to our incredibly successful
NYPD shield Network which is an
information sharing partnership between
the public and private sectors that has
expanded around the world since its
launch in 2014
now with the lavender Alliance we're
using our shield network to specifically
address security concerns in our LGBTQ
community and we're working even harder
to actively engage with every person our
Police Department serves your
participation and today's safety
briefing is a large part of this I want
to thank you all again for being here
and thank you for everything you do to
help make the safest large city in the
United States even safer together we'll
continue to build and strengthen our
partnerships with the LGBT community